being in Russell Wilson he is got a new
docu-series summer camp that was
released last week it's a three Episode
mini series produced by Russ's west to
east empire documenting a pre training
camp more on that coming up in a moment
I just saw this list Russ good morning
where Bucky Brooks of the NFL Network
said that Aaron Rodgers is overrated not
one of the top five quarterbacks going
into this season what do you make of
that headline and ratings and people's
opinions don't really matter about what
you do in the field and in games I think
that's the only thing I know he's a
great quarterback tirelessly every
Faroese town as it gets if you had to
replace yourself with any quarterback
who would you put in let's say fantasy
football who would you put in I would
say right now I would say Tom just
because he's won championships that's
what I love about winning so but other
than that I also say you know I know
about how Drew Brees plays the game to
you no one does you know I'm passer you
know broke all the records he's an
amazing person too as well so so I have
to pick you know Tom's you know you know
ability to be clutch and like and all
that and obviously Drew's abilities and
make you know throws and all the things
he's been a little done so those are two
guys I really admire laughs boy do you
want to know where you ranked on this
list I don't really need them that
doesn't matter to me
it could be motivation for you but it's
Patrick mahomes is one Philip Rivers to
Drew Brees three Tom Brady four and then
Russell Wilson jr. the third is fifth
well you know it's uh it's good to be in
good company not for sure how those guys
are extremely talented make a lot of
plays if they're great players or clutch
their winter so at the end of the day
you know you know you want to win that's
all about it to me
man you sound steamed you're gonna use
this as motivation this upcoming season
aren't you you know it hey I saw where
you were working out with Serena
Williams that was awesome okay how does
that happen that you're working out with
Serena well you know Serena and Sierra
and I and I wrote were all real close so
we uh we were actually in the South of
France Sierra was performing for Spotify
and can and so we went out there and
Sarina was actually out there at the
tennis academy out there and so we all
got together got the kids together and
then Reena and I wish I hey let's work
out together let's get this working and
so so we we got this working it got poor
got in and just just talked and just uh
just love this out love our mindset and
we're you know for a career and
everything else and so she's been a
great friend for us and and everything
else so it's always good getting the
kids together too so that's how we got
together and uh we had a good time
that's for sure who's in better shape oh
man she's used tremendous shape she's
always ready that she's always ready
when she was actually getting ready to
to go to go try to win a championship so
can you play tennis right did you play
tennis along with her I didn't get to
play tennis this time now she says she's
pretty tired I saw these numbers here I
don't know what these mean to you but
your touchdown to interception ratio do
you know where you rank all-time I don't
know what wrinkled I'm on no I you know
I know that's important stat though you
know the more touchdowns the better than
the less interceptions better so second
all-time
minimum of 3,000 pounds attempts Aaron
Rodgers the overrated Aaron Rodgers is
number one all-time
and he's far and away number one on this
list then it's you Tom Brady Drew Brees
Matt Ryan Steve Young Peyton Manning
that's pretty good company they're
second all-time touchdown to
interception ratio but I'm also curious
what is the most important stat to you
as a quarterback well I would say the
first thing is one you know I don't know
you know I want to be known as one of
the greatest when there's a long time I
think that's that's why I play the game
that's why we get to do what we get to
do that's why we had training camp
that's why we have you know the
offseason you know get togethers and
doing that and having fun and going
dinners and and and go on a gained just
enjoying one another the relationships
that you build it you know we come on
the field to go to go win you know and
that that's that's the mindset that we
had you know here that's for sure and I
think you know for a quarterback
standpoint is you know I think the I
think the statistical part is I do think
you know the passer rating and
touchdowns are important I touch
something right into interception ratio
I think that shows your production at
the end of the day you know you're not
going to keep me here if I'm not
producing so that's just that's just the
hard knock facts of you know reality of
the game and that's also the good
reality it's you get to control what you
can control in the end of the day you
know you put the work in Don the
offseason you get excited for what
you're gonna do and you know and players
go out make plays and you know you know
I love balling I love going out make it
plays trying to find ways to win these
Russell Wilson the Seahawks quarterback
joining us Dan Patrick show any added
pressure being the league's highest paid
player I've been you know uh I'm not
complaining but at the same time you
know you look forward to the opportunity
and the game guys have changed you know
it's still you're trying to you're
trying to get to the last one and try to
win the last one you know that's so that
attitude hasn't changed at all do you
get a paycheck
take city and do you get a paycheck do I
get a paycheck like every two weeks does
it come to the house or do you pick it
up at your locker house direct deposit
okay when I got my first I got my first
big deal I was a few years ago I got
that first check and I kept that and
then this one too as well but you know
the first big signing bonus check or
whatever so you know you keep those
things those are cool little things that
you frame to keep or whatever but you
know other than that I you know I did
direct deposit what did you drive the
first year you were in Seattle what was
your car
well I played pro baseball member so oh
actually I had a Mercedes yeah so like
are I really driven as I had as a
Mercedes at the time it was the GL so
now it's called a GLS okay and then so
now now you know a javo G Wagon which I
what do you drive you just you just show
sponsored by AMG you driving the
Mercedes you know I got it I got a I got
it sit in yeah thanks I like it okay
yeah
and I'm riding in style what did you
drive what was your first car you ever
had 69 Volkswagen it was green and it
didn't have floorboards in the backseat
so you can actually see the road if
anybody sat in the backseat they had to
have their feet up you actually had to
park it on a hill and jumpstart it I
didn't have baseball money Russ oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah hell yeah I was killing
it my first car was a was a red Jeep
Cherokee stick shift
he said whooping that thing around so
that was my first that was my first car
I like that did you buy anything when
you got signed this new contract did you
buy anything do you buy your wife
something yeah like what
you know I like talked about that stuff
but you know our nice little guest come
on we're both in love we like talking
about this that we are
but no I yeah always joy shoot your wife
and edit the kids you know just this
enjoying it as a family and jewelry I do
reason why I think that say yeah jewelry
yeah a little something I said and then
one of the things that I do for the kids
is you know I put I put money away for
their for the college fund so anytime I
play a playoff game I do that and then
also anytime something special you know
like like you know signing you know you
put money away for college funded so
that way they can have that for the rest
of their lives the new docu-series
summer camp whose idea was this you can
see it on youtube.com dangerous Wilson
how did this idea come up well the idea
of bringing the guys together was my
idea just hey let's get going we've done
it it pretty much every year since I
wrote a year and so but we wanted to do
this time was my creative director
getting along he's been with me for a
couple years now he's amazing he's super
talented was with NBC for for several
years and now he's working with us and
we get to do so many cool things Craig
shows and you know ideas and production
and everything else and so what what we
wanted to do is we wanted to tell the
story of these are these guys because
you know my teammates just because some
people don't know all the Seahawks fans
they're such ravenous fans but how do
you get to know these guys outside of
the game how do you get to know where
they're coming from you know their story
and then also seeing you know breaking
the ice a little bit of how we have fun
you know how we enjoy it all together
no yeah we put the work in but also it's
it's about about relationships about
it's a family it's a family atmosphere
it's gonna know you know I think it's
cool for the fans that be able to
connect to that and tell the stories of
guys like our sewer and jazz Ferguson
and obviously DK Matt Cass of the world
just different players you know and just
connecting in and how we do it and it's
been amazing it's on YouTube ever I can
go check it out tons of people are
watching it so it's a lot of fun our
guys nervous taking their shirts off
around DK Metcalf
no you know we had a the funny thing is
we played uh we played basketball in the
backyard and and you know we mean or sue
it we teamed up we played 114 games in a
row and I was talking trash to see Kay
you know because he got hurt all I can
all dig and everything else which he is
and so we exert on him abroad yang when
he was you know getting buckets all day
and sure enough he you know I said we're
gonna stop and I'm a twelfth king a half
of the 12th win in a row I said okay
after 15 games ain't playing no more
sure enough you know we played them in
the 15th game they had they had a
last-second shot my ball was going in
and his well it went went right in and
just beat us last second so but it was
entertaining it that's for sure
yeah he's a beast Hey great to catch up
with you as always Russ thanks for
joining us any other man man great
talking to you but for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]